all right what's up everyone we are back
at the blockchain economic forum we are
with Jordan Lyle
sup man hi there how you doing thanks
for coming on the show thanks for having
me
it's great to be here and Jordan is the
chief product officer yes at total
awesome and it's and it's from what I
learned coin base is a centralized
exchange centralized way for you to
store your cryptocurrency you don't
actually own your you don't hold on to
your key or your coins yeah and then
with total you actually do I get to keep
my key and my coins and then you guys
make it easy for me to just go and
transact and send that send my coins
through you to get it the exchange both
is that about yeah yeah no you're on the
right track very good very good we make
it really easy to participate in this
ecosystem of decentralized train so
you're right coinbase financed those
guys are doing a swell job however it's
kind of counter counterproductive this
whole technology allows us the
opportunity the benefit of holding our
own assets not having to trust a central
authority not having to rely on a bank
but essentially when we're investing
with coinbase we're buying it's we're
sending them our money our tokens our
coins and we're saying hey hold this for
me it contradicts everything that this
whole technology affords us so we're big
advocates that that users should hold on
to their own private keys at all times
and up until now the experience of
trading of saying hey I want to I want
to own less ether and more khyber token
or or you know whatever the token is
you're able to right now it's pretty
tough like there's there's there are
some interfaces here and there some
decentralized exchanges or Dex's as
they're called this one over here is
pretty tough to use that one has no
liquidity so really your options are
kind of limited we solve both problems
we make it easy to use
and we actually aggregate a number of
decentralized exchanges so we aggregate
several exchanges you're able to
participate in the liquidity in having
all these options at your at your
fingertips one platform trade directly
from your wallet we make it super
convenient okay so there's a couple
things there to unpack first thing to
unpack is the belief that the
responsibility of the owner of the
wallet should be in the customers hands
and show you so it shouldn't be that I
give wells-fargo a thousand bucks and
then they keep it in their account than
their coffers and then just let me use a
car to access it rather that it should
be that I have the thousand dollar
safely not just in cash so anybody can
just hit me and rob me but I have it
safely on my on my on my phone on
through and then I heck I can access it
through my pin or through my facial
recognition or my thumbprint or whatever
that's how I gain access to it and then
there's a you get a little like you get
a little like twelve words those twelve
words that you can write down and then
those twelve words you don't want to
screenshot it because then that goes to
Google or or Apple's cloud but if you
write those down then at any point you
can recover this wallet recover your
funds in that sense on when you're
opening up a new computer so so then
there's that aspect to it which is the
you own your account so so I'm I'm so
I'm using a total I'm using totals app
when I'm doing this correct yeah we're
an app or adapt decentralized
application and yeah no no logins no
registration no passwords on our
platform you know really the only way to
authenticate is by connecting a wallet
so you're right whether it's a wallet on
your phone like a like a like an app
browser on your phone or it's a hardware
wallet like ledger or treasure or it's a
web wallet like like meta mask which is
a browser extension makes it really easy
to browse these naps and interact with
the etherion blockchain
interesting metamath Mehta mask okay
yeah it's it makes it really easy that
Beckett really gained in popularity with
things in the last year like crypto
Kitty's a lot of people installed these
types of programs to allow really to to
allows users to get involved interact
with the blockchain rather than having a
separate wallet it really makes it easy
to use your browser interact with the
blockchain make transactions etc okay so
you're saying I either need a hardware
component or like a web app component
like meta mask so then when i download
total i can either have that hardware
component that then would that on that
on the data on the thumb drive i would
add my cryptocurrency to my total wallet
right so there's no there's actually no
there's no such thing as that's total
wallet
she has total wallet totals just a
decentralized exchangers yeah we're just
like the software layer so we're not in
exchange ourselves we aggregate multiple
exchanges you aggregate multiple changes
now why would i want an interface for
multiple decentralized exchanges well
why would i choose to use your interface
rather than going directly with my meta
master with my hardware key why wouldn't
i just go to those directions those
exchanges that's an option and you're
able to do that however you'd have to
jump around five or six and five or six
different exchanges really to get the
breadth of the tokens really to get the
the liquidity the volume sometimes the
volume just isn't there certain
exchanges are really tough to use this
one over here might do it one way where
this other exchange has a different way
of doing things and you handle that the
differences between those five
decentralized exchanges yeah we've we've
written a number of smart contracts
where all you do is you you connect to
our platform connect your wallet to our
platform once you want to make a trade
we find you the best price
so our smart contract goes out and it's
one transaction for you the investor or
the user and our smart contract will go
sell the tokens you wanted to sell go
buy this
tokens you want
- bye bring the tokens right back in
your wallet so it's really simple
instead of having to jump from exchange
to exchange you're doing it all in one
one platform okay let me see if I'm
following so let's use meta masks this
has to be a most relatable one so I'm
using meta mask and I want and I'm
storing my my value through meta mask is
that right this meta mask is a wallet
meta mask is a wallet okay so I'm
storing my value through meta mask and
then and then and then when I want to
use a fully decentralized exchange I
would use total because it aggregates
like five or so different decentralize
exchanges and then you will then most
effectively find the way for me to take
my etherium and make a purchase with it
or to exchange it to some Bitcoin so
something along those lines something
along those lines for now we're strictly
in the etherium ecosystem so ERC 20
tokens down the road on our roadmap we
have crossed chain solutions get into
Bitcoin and other ecosystems other smart
contract platforms so it's really just
ether and then other ERC 20 tokens other
than that you got it you got it right we
instead of bouncing around the different
exchanges come to total participate in
decentralized trade where no one can can
say no you can't make that trade we
compete for price on your behalf we go
and get you the best rate on this token
you wanted to buy and everything's
decentralized nothing ever touches our
wallets nothing ever touches our servers
it goes straight from your wallet
whether it's meta mask or Hardware
wallet but yeah in the example of meta
mask you'd make the adjustments you'd
say I want to I want to sell this token
by that token you'd confirm it and meta
mask you would say are you sure you want
to submit this and you'd say yes our
smart contracts in one block on the in
theory and blockchain so just in the
time it takes to to mine a block our
smart contract as mentioned sells the
token on this exchange for ether takes
the ether and then goes to another
exchange and buys the tokens you wanted
to buy so it's all happening in the
backend it's one transaction for you the
user multiple tokens over multiple
exchanges there's a lot going
on the backend all smart contracts all
publicly auditable so this is all this
is all out there ready to be ready to be
used ready to be audited but all the
tokens kind of come right back in one
seamless smooth transition yeah and give
us a couple examples of what I would use
then total for with metamath like what
would be something like a common thing
that the general public would use it for
yeah when you first when you first get a
meta mask wallet it's gonna be empty of
course so what you need to do is you
need to fund it with ether really the
easiest thing to do though we're trying
to we're trying to solve some of this
pain point but the most practical thing
right now would be to connect to
something like like a coin base by if
you all you have is US dollars all you
have is fiat money find a way to convert
US dollars to ether send the ether to
your meta mask wallet connect your meta
mask wall at the total go to total comm
tota le comm and connect to the wallet
authenticate with your wallet and you
would say so you we have a number of
tokens available so you would look
through our our list of tokens right now
it's 250 300 tokens and if there's a
proc that you believe in a project that
you say hey I want to invest in civic
token an O or an oMG or a wax token not
investment advice just just just thrown
out there as examples of tokens that
that are traded in our platform you
would say okay I want to and a little
bit more oMG and I want it alone X %
Civic token and C we advocate for having
a diversified portfolio and it's really
based on allocation so you would say
okay 10 10% of my portfolio I want in
this token 10% in that token and I want
to keep 50% in ether so you would get
your adjustments all lined up get
everything you know set up you would hit
submit and again our smart contract goes
out and buys everything you wanted to
buy yeah
and and just like that you have a
diversified portfolio
okay cool that that's a good relatable
example what are you most looking
forward to with blockchain technology
yeah really just it almost kind of
levels the playing field that says
heyyou person in random country no you
didn't go to Harvard but you have a seat
at the table everything's kind of kind
of evened out no matter where you come
from no matter what your background is
everyone's starting at Ground Zero in a
way like yeah there are blockchain
experts but they are as of a week ago
like we're all trying to figure this out
so it's it almost it really levels the
playing field I'm just excited kind of
the first thing that a lot of people do
they see the price go up in some of
these tokens and some of these projects
and they want to they want to
participate in this profit right so they
go and they invest and that's a really
good thing to do it's an easiest way to
figure out okay not only in do I
advocate investing but I also advocate
in moving money around removing crypto
around sending some to your friends move
from wall to wall just to get a feel of
how the private key system work totally
yeah and just to get a feel for how this
whole thing works and then like see how
you can get involved for me it was
building a product so working with the
team and building something for the
community where all these other things
like like turning a profit is less
important now that you're building
something so advocate just just getting
involved in whatever whatever it is
whatever your passion is get involved
help this community grow it's it's a
really exciting community to be to be a
part of and then what about what are you
looking most looking forward to with
decentralized technology in terms of
like liberation for people yeah I mean
if you think about it politically you're
able to move money across borders in
ways you just weren't able to without
this technology you mentioned the 12
word phrase memorized 12 words have
nothing on your person walk across
borders find access to a wallet type in
your 12 word phrase all you've you've
you retained that that value where else
maybe it would have been it would have
been taken from you had you cross
borders with with something on your
person next question is what do you
think
it's gonna happen with wealth inequality
as we have so many people that are have
so much and so many that have little
that are slowly coming up meanwhile
exponential technology is exacerbating
the wealth of richest end yeah that's a
really good good question I think we're
now at this point in point of history
that's the little guys is is able to get
a little little jump-start by that I
mean I think some of the the big players
in this space are worried about
regulations making sure that they get
this license and they're they're jumping
through these hoops while the rest of
the world are just they're building
they're getting involved so it's why
while kind of the heavy hitters in this
space so to speak heavy hitters
financially the wealth the people are
getting kind of stuck in their own ways
of jumping through these legal legal
hoops where potentially historically the
the the less sophisticated investor less
sophisticated person can tap into these
markets that are now that are now open
and available for anyone around the
world it's interesting cuz it seems
though the decentralisation technology
will both liberate people and make them
wealthier but also it will exacerbate
wealth inequality a little bit because a
lot of people that are in right now are
making a lot of money or just get richer
type of thing yeah a little bit
definitely what do you do you think
we're alone in the cosmos interesting I
I don't think we're alone no there's
someone else someone else out there
whether there have our best interest or
they're they think they're alone or yeah
whatever it is yeah I don't think it's
just us up here do you think there's a
designer to the world that we live in
personally I do yeah I do believe that
that that someone has has created us and
kind of set us into into motion yeah and
tell me a bit about that designer like
what does that designer like look like
or what variables today set to put us in
a motion I believe in the God of the Old
Testament and the new
personally and you know no no no
judgments here at all
but it's just you know personal to me I
believe that there's a god out there
that made us in our own in his in his
image whether it was through what we see
in terms of seven days in the Old
Testament or it was over the course of
the Big Bang I believe that there is a
God and he designed us in our image in
His image designed us in His image and
he cares passionately about each one of
us individually and he just wants to
once to see us happy he wants to yeah I
hope that the designer cares a lot about
us I hope I hope that it's not just
unleashing the variables off to do
whatever but hopefully there is some
care hopefully some love last question
what do you think some was a beautiful
thing in the world the smile of my kids
there's nothing quite like it it's
amazing as a father it mattered the
matter how bad your day was pop the kids
on your knee and and it just kind of
changes your whole mood and it's very
gratifying very yeah very fun that's
interesting you know when the bad day is
had and then the kids can their smile
and they're they're out there aperture
so open to knowledge into learning the
world around
them and then culture kind of closes it
over time yeah you're right I mean at a
young age a kid is so interested and
it's and it's only it's only from people
laughing or saying why are you asking
those questions or stop stop bothering
me go ask your mother you know like
those type of questions that type of
feedback to the kids start to kind of
close off Joran such a pleasure man
thanks a lot I appreciate it thanks for
coming onto the show this has been a lot
of fun we got to learn about total geo
tle comm links in the bio go check them
out and go like you know you made the
comment earlier but go and actually
start playing around go and put some
money into coinbase open up meta mask
that's a meta mask and then go and
funnel them into total and get a couple
of these other you said oh oh em gee
they go there's a couple of there yeah
again no no not advocate for these
products but they're but try this stuff
out like go through this process go do
it so you can get a feel for it you can
do it with what you do with five bucks
all right you can go yeah just a few
bucks get involved test it out kick the
tires yeah exactly at least go kick the
tires
exactly so go do that everyone thanks
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time make sure to give us a comment
below subscribe like the video go and
share with other people go tell to
people about this they'll tell to people
and sooner or later we'll get more
people caring about decentralization and
during us on patreon help us out help us
grow our media and help us continue
doing cool interviews like this today
thanks everyone
much love